alors c'est ici que habituellement est
depuis de longues années la journée
souvenir des déportés se déroule mais ce
dimanche 26 avril il n'y aura personne
pour la première fois depuis 1954 la
journée du souvenir ne se tiendra pas
pas de cérémonie pas de discours
seul le dépôt de gerbe est maintenue
pour conserver malgré tout le lien et
surtout la mémoire le musée de la
résistance de loris propose une visite
virtuelle confiné mais connecter les
visiteurs peuvent arpenter les couloirs
du musée
une manière aussi de prendre du recul
sur ce que nous vivons en ce moment
si comparaison il y a à faire je pense
que la solidarité fait partie des
maîtres mots en effet puisque l'après
guerre est ce que nous vivons
actuellement à montrer montre des
disparités dans les dents les
populations nous ne sommes
malheureusement pas tous égaux
socialement elle est important
effectivement d'être dans cette
bienveillance et de cette solidarité des
leçons à tirer du passé pour mieux
appréhender le présent
en 1945 les survivants souhaité que
jamais personne n'oublie leur sacrifice
une période dramatique qui rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui encore chacun est
responsable de l'avenir